digamos que la economía de un país está
estancada y que puede estar enfrentando
una crisis deflacionarias así que el
banco central trata de imprimir mucho
dinero con tasas de interés muy bajas
tanto como sean posibles digamos que la
del 1% y un inversionista puede llegar
al país y pedir prestado a este tipo de
cambio con esa tasa de interés también
digamos que en el resto del mundo en un
país ve se puede garantizar una
inversión segura con una tasa de interés
mucho más alta y en una compañía de este
país y con esta moneda se solicita y se
obtiene una tasa del 5% y como podrás
imaginar algunos inversionistas
oportunistas dicen wow podría pedir
prestado en el país a con el 1 por
ciento una cantidad particular de 100
que llamaremos dólares o yenes o
cualquier tipo de cambio con el que
llamaremos 100 más chiquitas y
continuando ellos piden 100 a chiquitas
a menos de que la tasa de conversión no
sea conveniente o correcta digamos que
en este punto del tiempo una chiquita
será igual a dos veces chiquitas por lo
que ellos ir a algún mercado de divisas
y podrán cambiar esto por veis chiquitas
y obtendrán 200 veces como tipo de
moneda y los invierten
en 200 veces lo que realidad su préstamo
era en as ellos piden prestado en as
chiquitas e invierten en betxí quitas
así que qué pasará bueno pues ellos
obtendrán el 5 por ciento en tipo de
cambio ve entonces el 5% de 200 ellos
tendrán 10 vez que aquí no le son
necesarios obtendrán 10 veces de los
intereses de cada año después ellos
pueden convertirlos pueden convertir
estos 10 veces y usarlos pero suponiendo
que el tipo de cambio y tasas obtenidas
son constantes y esta es una enorme
suposición los podrán convertir en cinco
us basándonos en el mismo tipo de cambio
y tasa y lo único que ellos tienen que
pagar es el 1% de us de intereses y
obtendrán 4 a chiquitas obtendrán 4 us
por año podrán guardar 4 a chiquititas
por año de manera totalmente libre
asumiendo que continuarán con la
operación después ellos puedan tomar los
4 así cambiarlos a cualquier tipo de
cambio que quieran serian 4 a chiquitas
u obtener 8 ve chiquitas por año tras
año y a este pequeño proceso de
percepción de arbitraje que se le
llamaría
trade es decir una operación
especulativa sobre la diferencia de un
rendimiento y es posible pensar de
manera consciente en donde estaría
reflejado todo este arbitraje bueno pues
el área principal donde se rompería y se
vería reflejado es que mientras tú estás
pidiendo prestado en la después base
inviertes en ve y todo esto con un tipo
de moneda apreciada o especialmente
tener que usar un tipo de divisa
puedes pues qué pasaría si incluso
tienes un interés disparatado y aún así
siguen obteniendo demasiadas veces
chiquitas y estas vez a su vez están
dando demasiadas y demasiadas a chiquita
por otro lado pensando los en términos
de ves aunque pienses que tu botín es
del 1 por ciento de interés también
sería apreciado así que en términos de
veces también obtendrías más y más ves
chiquitas cada año ahora lo que más
funcionó en la operación o lo más famoso
fue a mediados de los años noventas
cuando la gente comenzó a pedir
préstamos en japón pues ellos tienen la
tasa más baja en el mercado y con esta
tasa pedían prestado e invertían en
otros lugares como eeuu y especialmente
en lugares como islandia y así fue la
mayoría de la gente que hizo esto
imagínate demás
a la gente realizando esto pues son un
tipo de divulgación del factor y de
inmediato una multitud pidiendo prestado
en a y después yendo a invertirlo en vez
ellos tomaban ese tipo de cambio y la
invirtió en el tipo de divisa de color
magenta y si esto pasa enseguida tienes
el efecto contrario se obtiene un
beneficio en la parte superior del
interés espontáneamente pues esto
significa que la demanda de la divisa
debe subió y la demanda de la divisa a
bajo y esto es lo que esencialmente pasa
con japón y el resto del mundo cuando
japón tiene una baja en sus intereses
todo el proceso de adentro se acerca a
este